una alerta por calor extremo emitió el
servicio meteorológico británico debido
a las altas temperaturas que ha causado
sequías prolongadas sobre todo en el sur
de inglaterra y partes de gales lo que
redujo los niveles de agua en un embalse
local para paliar la crisis una compañía
de agua repartió botellas a los
residentes bueno este año ha sido
particularmente malo en el que no hemos
tenido absolutamente nada de agua no
hemos podido sacar nada de nuestros
grifos en absoluto pero todavía no ha
habido una solución a largo plazo y sólo
afecta a la mitad del pueblo así que la
mitad del pueblo tiene agua buena y la
otra mitad no así que claramente hay una
solución que funciona para la mitad
algunas compañías de agua ya han
impuesto restricciones como el uso de
aspersores y mangueras en algunas partes
de inglaterra los supermercados también
han limitado la venta de barbacoas
desechables que según advierten los
bomberos pueden prender fuego en lugares
secos donde a hierba
se espera que las temperaturas alcancen
un máximo de 35 grados celsius este
viernes y 36 en algunas regiones el mes
de julio fue el más seco desde 1935
debido posiblemente al cambio climático
las temperaturas superaron los 40 grados
por primera vez y ocasionaron incendios
cortas de electricidad y daños en las
pistas de los aeropuertos en las últimas
semanas en otros países europeos las
horas de calor han superado los 40
grados pero gran bretaña no está
acostumbrado a este fenómeno por lo que
está menos preparada que otras regiones